he's Russell Wilson jr. the third the
Seahawks quarterback he joins us now did
you do video games in college do you
have a favorite vitamin video games in
college I was kind of busy with that oh
come on
that the school and that 20 sports and
all that I didn't really have to they
had too much time what is your video
game of choice well I have to say Madden
obviously I was never really like a Call
of Duty guy who's like that I would say
I would say growing up when I was young
I played tons of Madden you know when I
was in Middle School on that who was
your favorite team that you would play
Madden with before you went to sea on
who whoever helped me win well give me a
team that you are a quarterback that you
love I love the plane with Drew Brees
you know Tom Brady let's do those two
guys they helped you win did you ever
pick the Seahawks defense to go against
you I did pick the well I have a plate I
haven't played Madden a little bit now
but um when I was younger I used to like
to see lots of colors so even being from
Virginia so I would pick him everyone
every once in a while I had Shaun
Alexander back in the day and stuff so
that was always cool how many tickets
how many more tickets do you have to get
going back to Wisconsin to play the
Packers well most of those fans are
season ticket holders people that I know
the back there and so there's those a
true develop and so they're already
going to the game so I actually don't
have to get too many this week but
obviously be exciting to go back to
Wisconsin such a special place for me a
place near and dear to my heart and we
get to play great football teams agree
on our attackers and they're coming off
a big one and all that so it'll be a
great game
a Big Ten title game how did you explain
that did you have any teammates who went
to Penn State who roughed you up a
little bit
yeah I have one of our tackles Garry
Gilliam who actually I played against at
Penn State when I was at Wisconsin we
beat up we being up on Penn State pretty
good but but you know we're
unfortunately I'm a little wager smaller
smaller ways or mean they they beat us
so I you know I got a podcast I got a
yes I give back I should say you should
have to wear a pant or cheers you some I
know right exactly so unfortunate
situation I was I was really
disappointed Alice II we were we were so
close so it was a great game and that's
what you want to see those in those
championship games you know you that's
why you play them that's well you have
all those you know games during the
season you get to the get to the end of
it and you want to have a close game
that people want to see these Russel
Wilson jr. the third Seahawks
quarterback you know how we came up with
that by the way Russ McLovin McLovin
called rg3 Seton do you have that
mclovin calling rg3 Robert Griffith jr.
the third so he called Robert Griffin
Griffith jr. the third and so it just
stuck in my head so it's Russell
Westbrook jr. the third Russell Wilson
jr. the third and I'm probably going to
say it one night on football night in
America but yeah we got it in our head
because McLovin screwed up rg3 trying to
figure that one out
when's the last time you spoke to Earl
Thomas just recently actually um you
know obviously he's he's a competitor
disappointing it was a great great
player I mean he's you know arguably
that you know one of the best safeties
ever played a game you know and he's got
a great player right next to him can
Chancellor it's a it's a sad situation
because he loves the game he's
passionate once helped us went but you
know the great thing about Early's is
he's gonna be back so he's passionate do
you know any time this year obviously
but on
you know he'll be back in he'll do
everything he can to rehab at the
highest level I was in he was just a
little disappointed and I think that
more than anything you know he's a tough
minded guy and he'll be back stronger
than ever
how's life for you by the way it's a
great man it's no right now I'm focusing
on win football games and that's but
that's the focus and and trying to
finish strong other stats and so when
you went in things are great you know
I'm just grateful that yes it's great
people around the office has been
grateful that you know you know that and
you get so much love around you and
you're passionate about the game that
you get to play too as well so life is
a-okay
you got names picked out for the baby
wouldn't tell you if I did know do you
know if it's a boy or not can't tell you
that I don't know if your wife ever
brought this up but I was in a movie
with her Sandler movie and we we
actually had a screening in Indianapolis
and she sat at a table right behind me
she ignored me the whole time but uh she
was like you were probably here no no I
was not I did notice her though I will
say that I said she's even prettier in
person and I my chair was our chairs
were back-to-back to one another and
everybody was talking to her so I played
it cool by not talking to her and then
she didn't she never said anything to me
but just tell her I said hello she'll
probably remember me from from the movie
but it was probably the eye connection
you guys had well I think we're just
actors it's just two actors
understanding one another and it's sort
of an unspoken understood you're an
actor right entourage you you really had
to
you had to act like yourself which is
sometimes tough that is actually the
harder thing to do so an inspection yet
you're having fun out there and that was
a that was one of the most fun things
I've ever been able to do obviously I
love the fact that you're involved in a
group to try to get basketball
back to Seattle how did this come up and
where do we stand with getting the NBA
back in Seattle well how about the
exciting thing in this city did you know
neither deserves it I think there's the
city is such a boring city and so many
great things going on here you know how
I always say that I don't want to tell
too many people about the city because I
don't want everybody to move here once
they because once she visited he's
pretty special but you know I I got to
know Chris Hansen a great great friend
you know that I've got to know over the
past you know a couple years here and in
Chris and I you know I've always told
him that you not wonder you know find a
way to have you know own a team one day
and hopefully multiple teams and and
that's one of my passions after I'm done
playing and all that kind of stuff and
so anyways um obviously the the Seattle
fans are so passionate about the Sonics
I mean everybody you go around you go to
the ball you go anywhere go to dinner
people wearing jackets hats all the time
you know the throwback you know jerseys
all this kind of stuff and and it's been
both on both of our hearts and and I'm
you know also Wally's too as well and
the Nordstrom family and stuff and the
hearts to help try to bring this team
back and and bring an NBA team here and
I think there's so many great things
about it too you know you know you
really think about it there's you know
when I was a young kid I wrote a cool
article on on on players shipping about
it you know but it's called boom
Shakalaka but when I was I was writing
them right again I was thinking about
you know when I was a young kid I said
play you know NBA Jam I used to I used
to play with with the Sonics you know
thinking about that team even though I
was you know 3,000 miles of wedding in
Virginia that meant so much and as a
young kid and yeah I think about the
generations to come you know here in
this in this area in Seattle and the
state of Washington you know it's a
basketball state first of all there's a
lot of great players that didn't played
here and you think about the young kids
and what it means and I'll never forget
the feeling when we won a Super Bowl and
we won that awesome Super Bowl Super
Bowl xlviii and we were able to come
back home and there were some millions
and millions of people and the
connection that I made from
all different socio-economic statuses -
all different races - all different
people all in the same city one of the
same colors and just so United and you
get to see these young kids faces and
how much they adore these players and
them how much they adore the situation
and what it means and it's a lifetime of
memories and and in this city is a very
very special place and so I want to do
everything I can to help bring this team
back with Chris Hansen and with Wally
Walker and the north's and family too as
well and but as you know hopefully bring
NHL team - but is it a an expansion
franchise or would you get a relocation
NBA team well at first first of all we
gotta build the arena
and so that's that you ask you know
what's next and so we have all we have
all the land and all that and and so
that's that's the exciting part there's
only one thing that we really need not
to vacation for the street and so you
know all the people in the city at
members it's kind of been able to
announce you know I was part of it and
and you know I'm partnering with with
this crew everybody in the city's so
excited you go to dinner and people are
going out we got to make this thing
happen in the city we gotta get the
street vacation and all that so it's a
big deal and you know it's um but it's a
game-changing thing and it'll be bring
more you know anything about the city -
there's a lot of homeless people here
too as well could potentially bring more
opportunities for for for people you
know for for jobs and all that so it's a
really cool situation it's not it's not
just about basketball games or hockey
games it's about people's lives and
changing hearts and souls too as well
and and bringing people uniting people
together so the city I think it needs it
and we gotta hit the street vacation
that's that the most important things
like that way we can build the arena we
have a state-of-the-art arena that we've
been working on and that's going to be
you know probably the most amazing arena
could ever go so it's gonna be really
really special so we gotta make that
happen and at the meantime also win
football games - that's the main focus
right now can you dunk my momma's one of
those you know you go - you know if you
go to a New York Knicks game you see
those people down a little Springs
that's that's me
but man you can't one of those out you
can't don't I can get up there I don't
know I can palm a ball I can I was more
one of sis guys you were John Stockton
is what you were I liked cp3 you know
it's like you know I like addition I'll
go flash and no school for you hey good
luck against the Packers good luck with
this venture as well and as always tell
your wife I said hello okay I will thank
you thanks so much guys
great talking to you go Hawks see you
Stan that's so Russell Wilson jr. the
third the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]